est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter ce
qui s'est passé le 3 janvier écoutez le
3 janvier ma mémoire est bonne c'était
un vendredi donc en fin de semaine le
week-end moi aussi me concerne j'étais
moi-même partie faire des livraisons a
un peu plus loin où je suis rendu à
rennes je reçois un coup de téléphone
aux alentours de 10h30
c'est mon beau père qui est une
entreprise familiale donc on fait des
livraisons il m'appelle et me dit que
bizarrement il n'a pas de nouvelles de
cédric son téléphone ne répond pas et vu
que son véhicule et les jo est localisé
il se rend compte que certes il est sur
sa trajectoire pour se rendre dans le
15e arrondissement effectuer ses
livraisons
mais il n'est pas sensé stagné à cet
endroit ou si l'entente c'est à dire
près de une demi heure il répond pas au
téléphone donc tout de suite ils
s'inquiètent mais ils me demandent en
même temps de patron andré qui y étaient
et bon vu que on est à peu près une
trentaine de livres heures donc il ya de
fortes chances pour qu'il y ait un de
ses collègues qui soit dans le port ils
écoutent t'inquiète pas mon avis c'est
peut-être fait contrôler par la police
contrôle de routine peut-être
éventuellement une infraction
je te tiens au courant moi je finissais
ma journée puisqu'elle avait commencé à
5 heures donc je finis mes livraisons
aux alentours de 11 heures
je l'appelle pour lui dire que tout est
ok et là il me dit écoute j'ai envoyé le
cas sur place à un coursier du type une
vigile est envoyé et bizarre moi et me
dit sur place il ya un attroupement
il a pu il a pu voir un camion de
pompiers des voitures de polices du
monde et il a croisé une ambulance enfin
le camion du samu avec trois motards dit
mais cédric il n'est pas sur place puis
quelques minutes après comme je vous dis
les véhicules sont géolocalisées il se
rend compte que le véhicule se trouve
dans le commissariat de proximité qui
est ruf la berre ou faber jeu ses pions
donc il me tient au courant bien entendu
me dit ah ah bah écoute désolé de le
dire mais effectivement à contrôler une
infraction ou bien en tous les cas
cédric il est au commissariat puis dit
ok il envoie un chauffeur qui est pas
très loin aux alentours de 11 heures ici
rang il se présente gentiment en tant
que salarié de la société et il dit
qu'il ya pour prendre des nouvelles de
cédric et savoir s'il est bien dans les
locaux et du pourquoi il lié au clan il
est reçu par un brigadier qui lui
expliquent dans un premier temps je
m'excuse désolé alors qu'il lui
communique la plaque d'immatriculation
du véhicule dans un premier temps il nie
le fait que le véhicule soit lights eric
soit la vue non ça me dit rien ça me
dirait un samedi rien donc le chauffeur
va pour repartir et mon beau-père lui
dire écoute tu retournes insiste parce
que le véhicule est géolocalisé donc pas
qu'ils me prennent pour un peu il est là
donc il y retourne et là ils insistent
là le l'agent de police prend la peine
de passer un coup de téléphone en
interne
il se renseigne il raccroche et il
répond au chauffeur qui effectivement
est le véhicule est là et cédric quoi
qu'il arrive il peut rien nous dire mise
à part le fait qu'il a le droit à un
avocat un médecin si nécessaire un appel
téléphonique
et ça ça nous inquiète encore plus parce
que pour quelle raison il n'aurait pas
appelé mais ce que je veux dire donc
j'ai cette information qui vient moi et
puis voilà ça commence ça commence à
m'inquiéter un peu ce que je me dis
après tout pourquoi il n'aurait pas
appelé ne serait ce que pour me dire le
trac est parue et là on conseille
sagement de rentrer chez moi mais moi
deux de suite j'ai ma fille qui à mes
côtés parce que c'était les vacances
donc j'ai prises avec moi je me suis
jamais me tenir compagnie sur la route
chinyama fille écoute en fin de compte
changement de destination tu mets
commissariat à ma charge donc j'arrive
là-bas à 14h47 à peu près rebelote jeu
donc je vais voir le brigadier je me
présente en tant qu'épouse monsieur
chouf ya cédric voilà le véhicule je
transmets encore une fois la plaque
d'immatriculation et là j'ai droit au
même discours il me dit oui il a le
droit à l'appel c'est bon rebelote il
dit exactement ce qu'il a dit à jean
charles suis dit ok je lui dis mais
c'est quand même bizarre que mon mari
n'est pas passé ce fameux coup de fil
auquel il a le droit je suis chez moi
mais moi la police ça me rassure pas il
ya quinze ans de ça je vous le dis on
direct il ya 15 ans avenue des ternes à
l'époque on lui 7e à paris dans le 17ème
à paris on avait une équipe de coursiers
à m6 avenue charles de gaulle 11 et les
livraisons pour m6 à l'époque et mon
mari sur sa dernière livraison et jeta
interpellé avenue des ternes pareil par
deux policiers et puis le ton de monte
et sont mêmes qui s'en rendre compte il
se fait étrangler mais violemment
il me raconte le récit de son histoire
je sais que ça n'a rien à voir mais
c'est sûr que si l'on veut qu'ils soient
rassurés comme voilà je vous explique
pourquoi il faudra rassurer puis vont et
donc de l'aïe
et ce jour là mon mari m'a dit écoute
sim avait retenu encore une seconde de
plus je serai pas là pour te raconter
mon histoire c'est que je vais vivre
longtemps
il m'a dit je t'assure j'ai vu mes yeux
révulsés
je me suis vu partir j'étais une
parenthèse donc j'ai dit écoutez moi je
suis pas très rassuré est ce qu'il est
possible que je sois accueillis pour
calais par par quelqu'un de chez vous
qui me disent un peu plus pour me
rassurer
dit que non c'est pas possible il est
majeur et qui peut pas une première plus
d'informations donc de là j'assiste
encore une fois et
et en insistant il me dit qu'on sein de
compte il est pas là mick son véhicule
et la gigue écoutez si le véhicule est
là c'est que c'est vous qui l'avez
récupéré donc vous à savoir un peu plus
jb neuf dans ce cas là il n'a pas été
interpellé il a fait un accident tout
bêtement donc dites moi quel hôpital et
l'été produit alors je peux pas vous
donner plus d'informations donc là vous
savez pas du tout ça fait combien de
temps que tu 10h30
et là il est quelle heure du matin là il
est
pas loin de 15 heures et là vous n'avez
toujours pas de nouvelles de notre
marraine cl je suis pas qu'il étrangers
qui ont dérobé son véhicule
mais c'est facile et au commissariat
s'il à l'hôpital voilà c'est là à ce
moment là je sais qu'il n'est pas au
connaught ça y est et donc à pas à 15
heures seulement à 15 heures et donc là
je me dis vas tout bêtement et
malheureusement il fait un petit
accident il est con dios donc je suis
toujours aussi inquiètes et j'insiste
pour avoir les coordonnées hôpital mptic
plus rien dire donc je me rends à la
caserne des pompiers
j'envoie mon fils son scooter à cochin
salpêtrière puisqu'il me lui-même
coursier quand il n'est pas allé se fait
tous les hôpitaux de paris donc il fait
déjà voilà on sera à l'aise j'appelle
donc là le truc c'est de savoir dans
quel hôpital il est hospitalisé
manque de pot on appelle georges
pompidou service des urgences ils nous
disent ils est pas là parce qu'il était
au service réanimation d'accord donc une
fois j'ai donc l'heure elle tourne et
que c'était avant je finis par chimie
par me dire bon et enfin après tout il
ya que qui servait ce qui se trouve donc
il faut que je retourne les voir comme
ça rires je retourne les voir et cette
fois ci je suis accueilli d'une autre
manière
on me dit qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
m'attend carrément et que je suis la
bienvenue on ne fut pas mon sac on ne
demande pas ma pièce d'identité
on me laisse effectivement il ya un
monsieur qui m'attendent voir ce que
toutes les deux non je suis tout seul à
sofia les pales à l'arbitré que la carte
est certaine elle est dans la voiture
avec toi bien d'accord donc je rentre
dans le commissariat là j'ai un policier
qui m'accueille qui me dit ah bah vous
tombez bien madame jbeil écoutez moi je
suis très inquiète pour mon mari est ce
que vous pouvez me dire à quel hôpital
il a été transporté une dit écoutez
justement nous on se pose beaucoup de
questions jeudi par rapport à quoi il
m'explique que mon mari a été interpellé
et qu'il était très énervé qui
comprenait pas pourquoi et que ça
tombait bien et pour je pourrais
peut-être l'éclaircir sur certains faits
je suis dit écoutez moi le plus
important pour moi c'est de me rendre à
l'hôpital à quel hôpital et georges
pompidou et je vais pour partir et à ce
moment là il me dit non suivez moi j'ai
besoin de vous parler asseyez-vous
machin ou cannes leur halle tour et
j'avais mes entreprises or là il ya un
truc bizarre je suis dit bon écoute et
puisque je suis là tant qu'à faire est
ce que à tout hasard vous avez des as et
des biens personnels à lui je les
récupère déjà là tout de suite
il met dans l'ambiance il me dit ah non
je peux passer sous scellés
et ea le procureur de la république qui
s'est saisi de la sphère gmail qui a la
chair et là il me dit ben voilà votre
mari il a fait un malaise et à ce moment
là il ya une de ses coéquipières qui
rentrent donc elle se joint à la
conversation et elle me dit ah vous êtes
la femme de ma vie je comprends pas il
était très énervé il fait beaucoup
emporté n'a pas compris il a fait un
malaise
d'accord et là me dit malaise cardiaque
on a essayé je suis témoin lui faire un
massage cardiaque et par la suite c'est
le samu qui a pris la main je suis dit
bon écoute et là dans ce cas là j'ai
vraiment plus rien à faire à vous jouez
avec vous je m'en vais je lui dis mais
je prends quand même la peine je dis
peut-être que vous avez fait une
interpellation peut-être un peu musclé
j'essaie d'en savoir un peu plus et me
dire ah non pas du tout elle joint ses
deux pieds il me dit que tu es moi
j'étais là je suis témoin je suis arrivé
à la fin mais je suis témoin il était
debout il est tombé tout seul non
d'accord ça me paraît un peu bizarre
mais sur le coup plus important c'est
d'aller à l'hôpital
donc je me rends à l'hôpital je préviens
mon fils je suis dit le de me rejoindre
l'as bages m'y rends avec ma fille est
arrivée là bas
de fil en aiguille on m'explique qu'il
est dans l'unité 3 donc je l'aperçois au
loin je vois ses pieds je les reconnais
mais bon pour moi il est arrivé donc du
service de réanimation et bêtement ça
fait un amalgame dans la tête vous savez
après le bloc opératoire on passe
souvent on ré a donc réanimation pour
moi ça rime avec l'éveil surveillance a
passé trop peur au contraire quand on
m'a dit réanimation samaras chez lui aux
urgences exactement
il y a il est allongé où je me dis
effectivement il est un peu
d'hypertension traité et donc il avait
son petit comprimé qui prenaient tous
les jours et voilà il s'est jamais
plaint de valeurs au coeur ou quoi que
ce soit mais il avait un peu
d'hypertension donc je j'attends bien
sagement et puis là aux lois il ya des
médecins
je suis rassuré parce que je me dis il
est bien entouré il est en train de
discuter avec eux et j'aperçois ses
pieds et gère l'un des médecins qui
seront vers moi avec une tête un peu
enfin beaucoup de compassion elle me dit
vous êtes
madame sous les halles épouse de
monsieur chouf viage vous dire que vous
êtes avec lui et om débat suivez moi et
là tout de suite elle demande la fameuse
clé vous savez de la pièce où est ce
qu'on annonce les mauvaises nouvelles et
donc elle installe au calme et très vite
elle me dit écoute et faut que je vous
le dise quand même assez rapidement je
suis très pessimiste en ce qui concerne
l'état de santé de leçons diagnostic
vital est engagé
je suis très pessimiste sur les heures à
venir on a beau qu'une malas à le
stabiliser
il a été transporté par le samu elle m'a
dit moi pour des raisons que j'ignore
enfin les ingénieurs m10 a sûrement une
asphyxie mais elle me dit il à faire
l'arrêt cardiaque je sais pas pourquoi
et donc un moment donné hamadi son
cerveau et son coeur n'ont pas été non
pas été oxygéné comme il le fallait
ça se trouve une seule une minute voire
deux minutes ça vous paraît pas beaucoup
mais il faut pas
il en faut très peu et elle me dit très
vite si vous avez des enfants de la
famille tout ça il est vraiment le temps
de les appeler et là j'ai mon fils et ma
fille qui sont déjà dans le couloir donc
elle avait l'air savoir de savoir de ce
qu'elle parlait donc très vite je leur
ai dit j'ai appelé ma fille j'ai
rapatrier sa mère qui était à biarritz
j'ai rappelé rapatrier ma mère qui est
en tunisie
enfin j'ai dit voilà tout le monde
entier venez c'est l'heure est grave
et puis après ben
comme on est croyant on a cru au miracle
alors que aujourd'hui quand on me dit
qu'il a eu une fracture du larynx
voyez ce que je dis bien sûr je pense
qu'il est mort sur le coup mais bon ça
reste une hypothèse on a cru au miracle
alors on a prié pendant deux jours à son
âge et de trois jours
la puissance de fja l'été la sofia votre
maman elle vous appelle vous annonce moi
je suis à ce moment là je suis je suis
déjà un peu stressé parce qu'on
m'informe contre c'est pas mon père est
plus que j'ai l'habitude mois enfin je
trouvais ça directement bizarre parce
que mon père je suis habitué à ce qu'ils
m'appellent tout le temps quand il est
sur la route quand les dix ans en chemin
pour travailler y livrer ses épices et
colis pour passer le et bien sûr oui
quoi ils nous passent nous appelle ses
il est équipé d'un kit mon grand père
est femme il a apprécié plusieurs fois
parce que certaines informations fausses
son véhicule et à ce propos à cause de
la police bien sûr parce qu'ils ont ils
ont soutenu que mon père avait le
téléphone à la main alors que il a
toujours ce pas là un kit savez tous
comment l'opinion comme tous les livres
oui zac te ment donc à ce moment là je
n'étais pas rassuré parce que depuis mon
réveil je l'avais pas eu au téléphone
donc je les appelais et c'est bizarre
mon père il me répond tout le temps donc
il peut être occupé même avec un client
il va me répondre
il va me laisser en attente cela me
faire comprendre qu'il est occupé mais
il va prendre le temps répond donc vous
êtes se disent passe quelque chose donc
là j'ai eu une montée de stress et de
panique mais il fallait pas que je la
laisse paraître parce que j'étais aux
côtés de mon petit frère
il s'agit de trois ans donc vous savez
les enfants de seconde il arrive à voir
à capter quand même quelque chose de
grave qui se passe donc une fois qu'ils
sont arrivés à l'hôpital
moi j'ai pu avoir par mon oncle que
juste l'état était grave et qu'il
fallait vite qu'on prenne nos gens m'a
beaucoup et vous et pêche de venir au
chevet de mon père tout à ce moment là
en plus vous connaissez paris avec les
bouchons rond et c'est la politesse
montrent la paoute la panique la panique
en arrivant rien de me rassure parce que
je le voit entouré de machines ainsi que
ba censées ces machines 10 passes et moi
je ne peux pas vivre
donc moi le premier réflexe est
débranché pas j'ai même pas penser à
comment ça s'est passé qui quoi enfin la
première restriction rassurer mon petit
frère mes frères et soeurs restés auprès
de ma famille
épris ce qui m'a fait ce qui m'a empêché
de pas tomber par terre à ce moment là
c'est prier parce que comme ma mère là
là là expliquer où on miracle et j'y
crois encore mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi
à quoi je crois encore le plus et c'est
c'est que tout ça se termine en paix en
justice que la justice soit faite parce
que après tout ça ces derniers jours où
j'ai pas dormi j'ai pas bu j'ai empêché
mon corps de se nourrir parce que
j'avais peur de pas resté assez
longtemps au prix de mon père parce
qu'on le veuille ou non on sait au fond
que c'est peut-être les derniers
instants je suis resté et au moment où
l'heure fatale bas à l'arrivée on m'a
dit que ça y est que quoi qu'il arrive
même avec mes prières et elles allaient
parvenir
et c'est là que tout s'est enchaîné
pourquoi comment ne pas pas qui est
moins gros qui est mon amoureux c'est
l'homme de ma vie
si ça parce que je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de filles beaucoup de pères vos
coupes percer un petit peu je prends à
peine d'être est aujourd'hui ici sur ce
plateau vraiment pour pour transmettre
cette peine parce que je pense que ça
touche souvent les mauvais les bons
coups tout et n'importe quel individu
humain m'enlever mon père un mois mes
frères et soeurs
certains qui sont derrière tu sais que
je ne retrouverai pas donc voilà ce qui
m'aide ce courage et sa dignité qu'on
n'arrête pas de nous dire c'est vraiment
c c'est la fois et on croit quand même
un peu encore à la justice
c'est la première fois que vous
témoignez soufia non c'est chez vous
c'est en fait la deuxième on va dire
mais ça prend une fois que je suis un
peu ça ça paraît un peu tôt à part les
coups pas lui en parler
vous arriverez surtout quand je le vois
comme ça était vraiment plein de vie
plein de projets pleins de bonnes
intentions s'était il avait un coeur
mais immense c'est c'est un grand gâchis
c'est une grande perte
est ce que c'est vraiment le consoler
ouais voilà on espère pour nous consoler
que ça se reproduira plus j'ai rappelé
que cette perte la cette douleur là elle
dira à guérir à d'autres personnes et
alors pêchera que sa sauce ça sera
commence justement doria aujourd'hui
vous êtes venu témoigner avec sofia
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que à qui vous en
voulez et qu'est ce que vous réclamez
que voilà qu'est ce que vous voulez
maintenant parce que c'est vrai que
cédric déjà franchement dans l'urgence
pour le principe et pour nous rassurer
qu on peut effectivement croire en cette
justice je comprends pas qu'ils aient
aucune mesure qui a été prise vis-à-vis
de ces trois ou quatre individus qui
sent directement lors il ya une enquête
en cours actuellement c'est ça c'est ça
il ya une plainte qui a été déposée sur
pour l'instant ils ont retenu homicide
involontaire moi j'ai un peu de
problèmes avec le mot involontaire après
bon voilà je perds pas la raison pour
autant et je rentre pas dans la haine je
me dis sur le coup quand tu es là ils
l'interpellent isis pas tiens celui-là
on va le tuer vous les avez rencontré
les avait vus m'écouter moi j'essaie
dame qui quitte la wii à part cette dame
a passé dame non j'ai rencontré personne
nous de ce que j'ai pu lire dans la
presse
on nous parle d'un individu qui serait
meurtri ils se sont pas manifestés on
n'a pas eu de nouvelles
on s'est beaucoup et qui était trop tard
de l'état de santé de mon mari on s'est
beaucoup inquiété de l'état
psychologique de mon mari moi mon mari
j'ai 8h04 il m'a appelé il m'a dit ah le
shérif ça va ça va la route ça se passe
bien on est tranquille et sinon toi ben
ouais ceci cela ou est ryan ce soir faut
qu'on lui parle c'est notre et un autre
est né on avait un petit on avait prévu
une petite réunion familiale avant que
le
le week end commence on s'est dit
l'avocat des pauvres on se débarrasse
d'elle parce qu'elle a tendance à
défendre son frère
on essaye de les diviser pour mieux les
dominer parce qu'ils sont aux nombres
savez je vous rappelle vous avez 5
il se défend d'entre eux donc on va
commencer rapidement à mettre une
stratégie en place au téléphone et je
lui dis mais sinon à part ça il y avait
un truc en particulier au chaos parce
que c'est en discutant on peut oublier
la raison dit non je t'appelais juste
pour dire que j'étais de très très bonne
humeur j'ai écouté de lave ou tant mieux
je suis dit bon écoute tant mieux ça me
fait plaisir quand tu m'appelles et tu
me dis que tu es super bonne humeur
voilà ce qui m'a dit et la veille de
leur conversation vous avez la dernière
conversation que j'ai eue au téléphone
est l'avant dernière c'était dans le
salon moi j'allais pour me coucher
on regarde beaucoup la télé à partir de
22h 21h on vous regarde mon mari vous
moi je vous regarde pas mon mari les
enfants vous regarde puisque moi je suis
aux fourneaux et il était plein plein de
bonnes résolutions il s'était ainsi si
dans un truc de sport vous savez avec
des électro machette ou à levallois zone
on verra donc il s'est plaint de bénodet
notions et puis s'est dit bon je me mets
à la soupe et fuchs effectivement il
avait pris un peu de poids
donc il a fait sa soupe aux choux et
avant de dormir je lui ai dit tu me l'as
mix et après je la rends je congèle
memic cela il m'a dit ouais t'inquiète
t'inquiète je fais je dis bon je sais
que tu vas pas le faire au pire des cas
à 5h jamie qui déjà et je la mets dans
jamais dans le congèle en fin de compte
il n'a pas mixer gelé pas mixer non plus
ea et puis voilà c'est normal c'est
votre centre ouest où vous nous
expliquer aussi le contexte wayne cook
est ce que est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous
fait confiance à la justice
je dirais pas que je fais pas confiance
parce que je suis une fille plein
d'espoir est très optimiste de nature
et j'attends toujours une belle issue
j'attends initial celui qu'elle serait
la belle et suppose qu'il ya plus de 10
sur la belle issue moi je pense que dans
un premier temps il faudrait qu'ils
critiquent et une prise de conscience
qui se remettent en question qui est un
intérêt général voyez ce que je veux
dire
jean françois toussaint peu dans le même
bateau parce qu'on est tous concernés et
qu on se dise bon certes cédric et
d'autre pourquoi la violence policière
c'est un fait
c'est quelque chose qui s'est vraiment
banalisée avec le temps c'est pas normal
c'est disproportionné c'est pas justifié
c'est donc on fasse de nous enfin de
vendre on se retrouve avec des policiers
qui nous font peur on se dit ils vont
ils vont perdre leur sang froid ils vont
s'énerver voyez ce que je veux dire ou
pas ils ont beaucoup de pouvoir
nous on a l'obligation de soumettre à
leur contrôle et cetera mais aujourd'hui
on est tous conscients qu'un contrôle il
peut très vite déraper comme on a pu le
voir pour cédric et dont et donc ne vous
attendez comme peine pour les personnes
qui une condamnation mais c'est à dire
de lourdes peines de prison
bien sûr on a ôté la vie de mon père et
coûter la vie ça n'a pas de prix
ça ça n'a pas de prix c'est en même
temps c'est dissuasif pour les autres
parce que là moi vous savez ce que je me
dis je me dis il n'y a pas un moment où
ce policier il a eu peur de le tuer il a
eu peur d'aller en prison
il n'y a pas un moment aussi retenu moi
j'ai mon frère qui fait du mma d'accord
donc les étranglements tout ça c'est une
pratique autorisée dans l'est mais ma et
d'autres armes à 100 dans les
compétitions dans les entraînements
jamais une mort et pourtant il ya
l'esprit de compétition voyez ce que je
veux dire l esprit de compétition savait
maîtriser mais il ya il n'y a pas de
morts donc ça veut dire que on leur
donne des techniques aujourd'hui qui
sont pas en mesure de maîtriser parce
que comment il va se défendre il va dire
qu'il voulait pas lui même il va se
retourner vers ces personnes qui leur
donnait ses pleins pouvoirs ou qu'ils
ont peut-être pas préparé à faire face
peut-être même à un contrôle on envisage
éventuellement bah ouais un contrôle le
ton il peut monter on peut tomber sur
une personne qui a un peu surmené qui
est pressé voyez ce que je veux dire
mais j'avais le sourire c'est gratuit la
politesse c'est gratuit
ils se plaignent ils disent qu'il ya
plus de respect c'est vrai on voit bien
autour de nous que le monde a changé et
c'est mieux quand même ils représentent
les forces de l'ordre ce sont des
gardiens de la paix c'est à eux de
montrer l'exemple et remet en donc dans
un premier temps vous abordez une
personne ça vous coûte quoi de lui dire
bonjour et même c'est pas parce que vous
allez lui adresser un sourire que vous
allez perdre votre crédibilité
ce rire c'est communicatif mais c'est
plein de petits trous nous a dit le
ministre de l'intérieur christophe
castaner parce que je crois qu'il vous a
reçu oui oui nous a reçus il vous a dit
moi quand vous arrivez dans le bureau de
christophe castaner il vous dit quoi il
m'explique qui d'une certaine manière il
a il a une part de responsabilité
d'accord il s'excuse compet compatit il
présente ses condoléances
mais après par rapport à nos demandes
c'est à dire que les policiers soient
suspendus c'est la pratique du caca de
mettre un terme au moment de mettre un
terme aux yeux et avec qui accompagné de
votre fille d'accord deux de mes deux
aînés du grand emprunt de ma belle-mère
d'accord mon beau père ma tante et ma
belle soeur la soeur de mon de mon mari
d'accord donc il vous dit que par
rapport aux sanctions pour l'instant
rien de rien faire oui il peut rien
faire du tout on voit que c'est un homme
qui a les mains liées
il est entre deux feux way ce que je
veux dire entre le voyez ce que je veux
dire prendre un tel système voilà oui
oui moi je vois par rapport à ce qui me
dit puisqu'il constate quand même avec
nous qui effectivement ça c'est pas
normal qu effectivement ça s'est
banalisé qu'effectivement c'était
disproportionné qu'effectivement c'est
très grave ce qui s'est passé et que
s'il remet delà il avait eu le rapport
avait déjà un rapport qui avait été fait
il avait eu le rapport yahya yahya un
premier rapport c'est le même d'ailleurs
mais très vite dans l'auto psy il
explique bien qu'il ya eu une axonaise
sicsic et à provoquer
l'arrêt cardiaque et l'arrêt cérébrale
je sais pas si ça se dit et qui a une
fracture du larynx donc y regrette il
est compatissant mais je vous dis nous
on a on en a profité on a demandé à nous
à nous voir donc bien sûr on a des
choses a rejoint dick et donc nous ce
qu'on a demandé c'était simple et
s'était largement justifiée avec ce qui
s'est passé puisque je vous dis moi
j'imagine déjà la défense de ces
policiers on voulait pas on voulait pas
ce que vous auriez mais quand même
qu'ils qui vous appellent ou qui
viennent vous voir vous et votre famille
c'est des policiers oui ce qu'ils
viennent nous voir n'ont peut-être pas
mais ils ont ressenti un sentiment
grisant
il aurait pu il aurait pu témoigner
témoigner de leur regret il aurait pu
demander pardon
alors est-ce que vous pensez que est-ce
que ça je m'adresse à arak elle est ce
que si les policiers avaient demandé
pardon où s'était rendu chez la famille
shaw via ou leur avait envoyé à un mot
est ce que ça aurait pu être retenue
contre eux lors du procès non mais
disons que s'ils admettent avoir eu des
gestes qui ont directement provoqué la
mort de votre papa de votre époque de
jouer contre ces autos incriminantes
c'est ça alors cela dit la justice en
général apprécient lorsque les personnes
mis en cause poursuivies manifeste c'est
un regret à ce qu'ils auraient pu dire
voilà c'est aussi le rôle de la justice
que les victimes puissent obtenir
réparation
alors là c'est irréparable mais au moins
ce sentiment de regret qu'ils soient
exprimés c'est quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre on va dire d'une règle de vie en
commun qui est qui et qui est vieille
comme le monde et la justice alors elle
en tient compte bien alors sofia et
doria on va avoir le sentiment de 2,2
chacun ici autour de la table on est
tous très émus un bar par ce témoignage
en plus vraiment je tiens à souligner
votre gré de courage et là la façon de
s'exprimer aussi de sofia qui est
magnifique nous a fait passer un message
exceptionnel karim
quel est votre sentiment vous sur cette
affaire au moins ça vous ça vous révolte
choucair fut d'abord bouleversé de les
entendre c'est une famille qui j'ai pas
mis de nous comprendre l'émotion de
karim on est tous très émus gvt eric
naulleau très ému jimmy or ans bernard
et qu'est ce qui l'émeut vrac elle c'est
vrai que là tout le monde a du mal à
prendre la parole mais non mais oui on
est viré par les deux de courage de
dignité moi c'est ce que je retiens vos
témoignages
après vous nous avez appris des choses
c'est que en plus du drame une quelque
chose d'inqualifiable c'est le
dysfonctionnement que vous a promené de
lieux en lieux
donc il suffit pas que vous perdiez
votre votre père ou votre mari
il faut que vous ayez l'impression qu'on
vous cache quelque chose qu'il faut vous
par courrier tout paris dans les
conditions que vous que vous avez dit
donc je trouve ça scandaleux après sur
le fond de la sphère comblé par les
images parce que même si votre mari
s'adresse aux policiers de manière
véhémente il n'est pas hors de contrôle
il est seul il est entouré par plusieurs
fonctionnaires de police on se dit que
c'est complètement disproportionné au
moyen on voyait pas le danger
non nous on voyait pas de danger
imminent après moi je l'aï dit vous dire
qu'il est assez nerveux d'orient ah non
j'ai pas dit ça j'ai dit qu'il était
voilà qui dit que ces algues l'armée
gueule pas pourrir eagle pas pour rien
mais dans un premier temps bain dans un
deuxième temps puis dans un troisième
temps et le ton il peut monter ça peut
être avec ses enfants ça peut être avec
julie fier mais c'est justifié derrière
c'est quelqu'un qui a toute sa raison
c'est quelqu'un qui est très exposés à
l'accident en mesurant en scooter dont
il meurt il prend ses précautions c'est
quelqu'un qui est très exposé aux
contrôles de police et fait entre 200 et
300 km par jour en scooter il peut à
faire jeu en fin de mois il peut faire
jusqu'à 100 livraisons par jour donc
cent fois ce que je veux dire mettre le
scooter sur béquilles machin venir il
est très professionnel il a commencé ce
métier à l'âge de 14 ans entre temps il
a fait d'autres choses
il est revenu à ce métier parce que
voilà la vie elle a fait que on n'avait
pas trop le choix et chien prisée où
percent quelqu'un de très diplomate
c'est à dire il va prendre le temps
d'expliquer de bien s'exprimer il va pas
se laisser faire
vous me disiez que
ça vous touche et la manière dont je
m'exprime et donc je vais passer mon
père qui l'a tronçon la transe peas et
personne d'autre ma mère et mon père
donc ces mamans pour vous donner un
petit espoir et un petit aperçu peut-on
reflète ses tombereaux fait vraiment le
caractère l'état d'esprit le
comportement la vision des choses c'est
c'est ce qui m'a transmis commentaire
pardonnez moi pour moi vous avez fait le
lien une fois que vous avez vu le top 6
et que vous avez donc su qu'il y avait
une fracture du larynx
à partir de ce moment là comment du coup
vous êtes vous avez fait le lien avec
laquelle la notion du placage ventrale
et du coup faire cet appel à témoignage
parce que dans cette affaire je trouve
ce qui est encore plus révoltant c'est
que s'il n'y avait pas ces images ses
clips
peut-être qu'on serait encore dans le
déni est dans le mensonge il ne faut
encore notre malheur dans notre malheur
contrairement à d'autres familles qui
clament encore justice et qui sont dans
l'ombre
dans notre malheur on a eu de la chance
on a eu de la chance et avenue de
suffren au pied de la tour eiffel il ya
énormément de énormément de demande de
passage il a beaucoup de caméras surtout
c'est ça il ya beaucoup de caméras et là
on allait en commence à avoir des vidéos
mais je pourrais pas en dire plus que ça
parce qu'il ya une entraide qui veut pas
vous me dire voilà qui est en cours non
le ministre nous a pu nous a promis la
plus grande des transparences la plus
grande des arrive à vous tenir au conte
christophe castaner de devancer un
enquête oui par rapport à même ce qui
peut faire changement par rapport au
traitement de l'anc est pâle enquête au
niveau de la justice mais plus à ce
qu'on a demandé le placage montreal et
et banyuls accros au site qui a évoqué
le dossier vous en attendez quelque
chose du président de la république
aussi si peu pour moi il est lié au
sommet il est au dessus
donc je pense que que lui vraiment il
est en mesure de prendre une mesure
vraiment comment dirais-je
tu peut tout changer mais changer la
donne est déjà dans l'urgence parce que
là il ya vraiment eu que vous aimeriez
que l'enquêté aille vite nommé au delà
de ça déjà c'est d'ailleurs pour ces
techniques je vous dis qu'il ne maîtrise
pas et d'ailleurs on le verra alors du
procès ils diront on ne savait pas on
voulait pas en âge où ils vont se
défendre d'une manière ou d'une autre
parce que bien sûr que je vous dis au
loin quand ils la perçoivent et dix
patients suivant va le tuer en sus on
est clair mais de la bande bien sûr
c'est disproportionné etc
mais un moment donné il va se défendre
et m'en dire on voulait pas mais ils
veulent pas ils le font quand il ya un
danger quelque part il faut prendre ses
responsabilités d'un j'appréhendais le
procès se fiant j'appréhende pas ce que
fait je suis j'ai une part d une pâte
existe à sion pour enfin savoir bas ce
qui va se passer parce que jour
d'aujourd'hui
déjà que c'est difficile de perdre un
papa de faire son deuil
on est en train de traverser un combat
donc j'aimerais que ce combat se termine
vite et en notre faveur et en faveur du
peuple en fait si lui s'il arrive à ce
que la sanction la peine ne soit pas
celle que vous espériez vous appelle
vous ferez appel bien sûr et c'est pour
vous c'est ce sera une deuxième agence
déception exane est déjà la première
c'est une injustice
donc là ça sera une deuxième injustice
et je pense pas que le gouvernement va
laisser alors c'est la justice qui va
qui va travailler ses contrats de façon
ici dernier souffle un clic sommes là
c'est vraiment si vous avez confiance en
la justice ou pas si la justice va bien
faire son travail au sénat mais moi j'ai
carrément envie de croire en la justice
je vous dis je vous dis honnêtement mais
déjà là ça commence mal parce que là
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont un
traitement de faveur
d'accord parce qu'on sent pas suspendu
ses lauriers qu'ils soient suspendus la
mairie les médias médiatement ils sont
impliqués quoi qu'il arrive je vous
enverrai justement tient carrément pensé
qu'il devait il aurait dû même si on
sait pas voilà la semence et qui doit
être suspendu sur le champ
moi je pense que c'est un minimum très
franchement tu es quelqu'un par le matin
il est livreur il est père de famille il
ya un contrôle routier même s'il a fait
preuve un peu doute rage comme un peu ça
peut arriver se marie pas la mort comme
et je veux dire à un moment donné
c'est hyper gravissime une famille qui
explosera fait je veux dire moi moi
pourquoi je suis bouleversée parce que
j'aime on peut tous se voir dans leur
camion moi j'ai des filles quand
j'entends sofia j'entends mes filles je
dis c'est un truc de fou quoi vous
pensez
et puis quelle dignité par contre lequel
dignité j'ai pas entendu de haine ce
soir j'ai pas entendu de rageux
j'entends juste des appels à la justice
ils ont envie d'y croire c'est sa
demande et demande un moment donné mais
cette non justice au moins ça permettez
nous de faire notre deuil
notre papa est parti travailler il n'est
pas rentré le soir ne qu' il est mort
parce qu'il ya une intervention
policière scandaleuse inacceptable quoi
qu'on puisse nous dire ça pas lieu
d'être a pas lieu d'exister
ils demandent du juste la justice ya
plein de gens qui auraient des discours
de violence de haine qui seraient
pleines de fiel
ils sont pas dans ce cas-là c'est de
l'amour ils sont croyants ils sont
spirituels
ils ont envie d'être positive [ __ ] ils
ont une force extraordinaire ces gens
ils ont une dignité fabuleuse moi je
suis impressionné oui mais je crois
qu'ils arrivent à raison moi je suis
admiratif parce que je serais incapable
de faire ce que vous faites je me le dis
avec beaucoup de sincérité je retiens
ému je vous sens apaisé je vous sens
calme et je vous sens vous voulez savoir
réellement et vous voulez de la justice
tout simplement vous voulez pas de haine
dans vos propos et c'est moi je suis
admiratif de sa dent comme karim je
trouve inadmissible qu'on n'ait pas pris
une décision de dire on les juge pas
varié dans kate on les juge pas on fera
ce qu'il faut mais c'est vrai que la
demande des choses c'était comme des
suspects peut-être que la moindre des
choses c'était que le ministre de
l'intérieur viennent vous voir
c'est pas vous allez me voir ce pari de
la part des fonctions de police même pas
un appel pour jamais condoléances voilà
on n'a pas envie que ça se passe comme
ça même si il sait pas de dire on c'est
notre faute et pendant tant de
condoléances on compatit autres peines
même pas ça après après ça ça mais pas
ça les met pas en cause à ce jeu je vous
dis à mon avis je pense qu'ils ont aussi
dit ils ne peuvent pas se permet il
doivent pas prendre la décision seul
d'appeler les familles je pense qu'ils
ont eu des directives comme quoi il
fallait pas les appeler chemise en jean
mais agile les chemins de ma pré c'est
l'humain qui parle donc je pense que le
ministre est humain
c'est pour ces policiers pas
malheureusement aux policiers de le
faire si on me disait ça missiles
auraient dû les valeurs d'écouté alors
je veux pas dire déjà à votre apn et
puis on va faire toute la lumière sur
cette affaire c'est la main des choses
mais vous dit quoi christophe castaner
pour lui dit que vous auriez aimé que
les policiers qui ont commis
voilà ce que je vais dire cet homicide
involontaire volontaires commises sur
votre mari vous vouliez qu'il soit
suspendu il vous dit quoi vous réponds
quoi vous dis que c'est pas possible
pourquoi dit qu' il ya une procédure et
puis je tourne à ce moment là vers
quelqu'un qui fait partie de la police
dont je sais pas j'ai pas retenu le mot
il prend des notes
il comprend qu'on prend notre demande de
sueur mais voilà je vais revenir vers
vous non il ya beaucoup de compréhension
mais meyer rien de concret dit que
c'était donc il vous a dit pour
l'instant c'est pas possible
non il n'a pas dit que ce n'était pas
facile faire le nécessaire avec ses
pouvoirs qui enfin avec ce qu'il a enfin
ce qu'ils peuvent
il va faire le nécessaire pour que ça
avance et pour que ça se déroule comme
on le demande d'accord monsieur roux qui
vous a pas dit non et là vous financer
des camps cette rencontre c'était mardi
mardi vous avez des nouvelles depuis non
non à cornes et jodie vous en attendez
quand il vous a dit qu'il vous auriez
des nouvelles qu'on il est resté assez
évasive à votre interlocuteur maintenons
nos avocats nous avons quinze autres en
tirant la fonction mais avant le temps
de la justice là il peut y avoir le
temps de l'apaisement
vous imaginez un geste d'apaisement même
si les policiers peuvent pas appeler
directement ce que vous avez dit c'est
vrai on peut imaginer quand même que par
rapport à un drame pareil
voilà on fasse un geste qui est quelque
chose qui reconnaissent votre douleur
votre père je pense que dans un premier
temps ce serait une satisfaction pour
vous quand même une forme de
reconnaissance
et vous savez bien que le temps de la
justice est évidemment plus long le
ramène procédures internes à la police
d'abord qui aura sans doute plus vite
que la justice migros - l'apaisement je
crois que c'est le minimum
on vous doit et vous l'avez pas encore
obtenu quoi je le regrette je pense
qu'il faut que l'enquêté aille le plus
vite possible pour que vous ayez des
réponses parce que ce qui est terrible
c'est de ne pas comprendre et pour tout
le monde tout le monde va avoir des
réponses parce que personne ne comprend
ce qui s'est réellement passé on peut
pas imaginer
en 2020 on puisse sur un contrôle de
police
mourir on ne peut pas imaginer non plus
que ces policiers
volontairement et vous le donner la mort
est la seule chose qui compte c'est de
comprendre ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est la seule chose qui pourra mener à
l'apaisement et à la justice sociale à
l'impérieuse nécessité c'est que cette
enquête a et vite pour qu'ils aient des
réponses parce que c'est un cas pas de
réponse il ya beaucoup d'angoissé et
c'est là où c'est terrible de dire que
vous a tourné aujourd'hui c'est ce
qu'ils attendent aujourd'hui la famille
attend voilà aujourd'hui quand l enquête
aille vite ils veulent savoir ce qui
s'est passé et on peut les comprendre
dit me morel je présente mes condoleance
déjà suire en bouleverser parce que
comme car il le dit on se projette je
suis aussi papa j'ai des enfants en bas
âge et ccc enfin voila c'est compliqué
passé mais c'est bien de vous parce
qu'on met une histoire sur un mort en
fait souvent dans les faits divers on
dit un mort partie 1 mort parler on
comprend pas qu on bouleverse des vies
dans votre histoire
rien qui va a vraiment rien qui va pour
rappeler aux gens la fracture du larynx
alors le larynx et que vous êtes médecin
voilà le brassard le larynx et un tuyau
fait de cartilage qui sert à respirer
lorsque ce cartilage et écraser fracture
est déplacé l'oxygène ne passe plus
quand l'oxygène ne passe plus le coeur
s'arrête et ça conduit à l'arrêt
cardio-respiratoire l'arrêt cardiaque
j'ai interrogé des amis médecins alors
dix ans mais vous avez déjà vu vous des
fracture du larynx et m'ont dit oui dans
deux situations
la première chez des gens pendu et la
deuxième chez des gens victimes de
strangulation donc les choses semblent
assez clair là pas besoin d'éviter
images on les appelle sont terribles
mais trois hommes sur un homme à plat
ventre après avec son casque je ne sais
pas quelles étaient ses chances de
survie
mais je pense qu'elle était très limité
à ce moment-là et autre chose que contre
laquelle je suis vraiment en colère ces
traitements médiatiques m'a beaucoup
parlé d'un contrôle musclé de dérapage
d'un homme qui serait vraiment et un
article que je vais pas citer moi c'est
la honte du journalisme qui essayait de
relater le passé de votre mari doivent
d'abord il a eu des amendes comme si
avoir des amendes justifier ce qui se
passait alors c'est simple on est dans
l'impression donne et c'est la fracture
qui en train de s'installer entre le
peuple et la police
on a besoin des policiers m'a besoin
d'une police vertueuse une police
exemplaires et on ne peut pas pardonner
à la police les mêmes choses qu'on
pourrait pardonner à une personne lambda
je sais que moi quand je m'exprime si je
commets une erreur
sacré en tant que médecin et c'est
normal car on doit honorer notre
profession mais lorsqu'on s'intéresse à
ce qui s'est passé au niveau des
policiers aussi pourquoi ils n'ont pas
été sanctionnés d'emblée mise à pied au
minimum on est dans une période où
quelqu'un un éboueur qui va se reposer
qu'il va être des noms à qui on va
balancer sur les réseaux sociaux sa
photo va être viré mais des gestes qui
vont entraîner la mort de façon
volontaire ou indirecte on nous dit un
non pas de suspension à titre provisoire
et 2 on ne va pas interdire la technique
qui va conduire à sa mort
et c'est ce qui fait que dans la tête
des gens il ya une fracture et cette
fracture elle en train de s'agrandir
parce que malheureusement votre papa et
votre mari ne sont pas les seuls qui ont
été victimes de ce genre de procédure on
a vu la sphère adama traoré lamine
diagne en a eu plein à chaque fois on
parle de contrôles musclés ont dit oui
mais c'était des délinquants même si
c'était des délinquants et même s'il a
été respectueux il ne méritait pas ce
qui s'est passé et je repense à cette
policière qui droit dans les yeux pieds
joints vous dis non non j'ai assisté à
la scène
il s'est écroulé tout seul richard je
veux le rapport scandaleux
abba parole des policiers lorsqu'elle
est travestie lorsqu ils mentent
après la mort si je suis désolé on peut
avoir 99,9 pour cent des policiers
vertueux les brebis galeuses ceux qui
vont déraper peu importe vos salir la
profession et il est urgent d'arrêter de
travestir la réalité est que justice
soit faite et c'est le minimum que il ne
soit pas muté faut qu'il fasse autre
chose on a l'impression que c'est une
forme d'impunité vis-à-vis des policiers
on l'a eue avec l'époque des gilet jaune
des gens perdre un oeil
moussu bongo père lionel était là il
fallait pas être là des gens aux idées
mâchoire brisée bon il était là mais là
ça va au delà de ça dont il acclame
chômage et en plus éthérée denaisis
malaisie mageret va souvent on ne sait
pas mais là il ya des images de ses plus
grands médias surtout une autopsie avec
une fracture du nez en plus et en plus
de ça j'ai vu un on s'est prononcé sur
un état de santé au préalable à dire
m'aimait et j'ai vu ça va très vite et
étouffés parce qu'ils ont compris que
c'était une arnaque en dix ans mais il
avait peut-être des problèmes cardiaques
antérieures sous-entendu que les
policiers ne seraient pas responsables
et que une pathologie préalable pouvait
peut-être entraîné sa mort j'aimerais
dire que c'est aussi pertinent que dire
qu'il avait un corps au pied ou de
l'asthme ça n'a strictement aucun
rapport
n'importe qui en bonne santé vous lui
faites une clé d'étranglement vous le
mettez sur le ventre trois hommes vous
l'écraser il un casque il décède et qui
habite
journaliste ou non non c'est la
préfecture a relayé en interne et au
fait que ce soit dit en passant il avait
une pathologie cardiaque sous jacentes
je peux vous dire que alors moi je bien
sûr il ya une enquête bien sûr mais tout
ça c'est du cinéma est la seule chaussée
il a été victime de strangulation
fracture du larynx s'est entraîné sa
mort justice doit être faite et
rapidement on doit pas attendre une
procédure sa 107 ans au calme et les
choses il faut montrer l'exemple
les policiers ne sont pas tous comme ça
mais ceux qui commettent ce genre d'acte
faut qu'ils soient sanctionnés mais là
où l'armée a raison c'est que et il a
écrit fils et sur un point je pense
c'est important pour ceux qui nous
écoutent
il en va quand même de la confiance de
la population française à la police et
la justice ont expliqué c'est ça qui est
important
et là ils se rendent pas compte en
orange réagissant pas comme il se doit
qui met à mal cette confiance même chez
des gens qui ont envie d'y croire qu'on
vide croire la justice comme il croire à
la police qu'on me croire que l'immense
majorité fait son job correctement
là on commence à douter et on se dit
mais nous aurions pu être à la place de
cédric n'importe qui aurait pu être à la
place de cédric daury et on aurait pu
virus qui l'a vécu très franchement la
mise à pied même pour les fonctionnaires
de mon chéri je pense que c'était le
mieux pour vous un potager même amoureux
j'ai mes ports et des choux doria et et
sofia jouer je vais bientôt vous libérer
mais je voulais juste vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que ça vient un petit frère de
trois ans comment vous avez trouvé les
mots pour lui dire que keith où vous
l'avez dit
bon d'abord il s'est rendu à l'hôpital
dans qu'il a vu que si on lui explique
qu'elle n'a pas vu non je ne vis que son
papa était en souffrance qu'il était
endormi et qu'on espérait qu'il allait
se réveiller
donc avant de partir je suis dit bon
écoute tu vas y dormir chez son temps
avant de dormir tu pries tu demandes au
bon dieu que papa il se réveille et que
sign donc lui gentiment il m'a dit maman
je vais faire la prière et je vais lui
ramener un cadeau fautive à se réveiller
d'accord on est resté sur sa rapprochent
et me font malheureusement le miracle
s'est pas produit comme je vous ai dit
il aurait fallu un miracle c'est un
miracle toute façon va pas polémiquer
dessus et il ya trois-quatre jours comme
l' affaire a commencé à être médiatisé
et tout je voulais pas que je me suis
dit j'aimerais pas qu'ils l'apprennent
par un enfant ou donc vu qu'il était
demandeur et qu'il voulait retourner à
l'école j'ai dit bon là faut que je me
lance je lui explique donc j'ai fait ça
de la manière la plus simple
mon mari c'était vraiment un bienfaiteur
il avait même des projet d'orphelinat il
avait des projets fous est très jeune il
a expliqué issa que ce n'était pas tous
les enfants qui avaient la chance
d'avoir un papa et une maman et que
parfois il y avait des personnes âgées
qui étaient abandonnées il lui est
toujours expliqué depuis qu'il était
petit qu'il fallait qu'il ait une
attention une gentillesse particulière
pour les orphelins et pour les personnes
âgées
donc il avait déjà une notion de
l'orphelin et c est donc qu il
comprenait que baye des gens qui
mouraient quoi donc moi je les prie
gentiment au calme et je lui ai dit tu
sais ça c'est à dieu qu'on appartient et
parfois ben dieu il nous rappelle à lui
et on retourne vers lui est ce qu'on
espère c'est d'aller au paradis parce
qu'il ya ce monde ici bas
et puis un autre monde et c'est un monde
qui est magnifique et maintenant tu vas
pas prier pour papa il se réveille mais
tu vas prier pour que pas que dieu ils
permettent à papa d'y aller dans ce
monde du 10 mai donc je lui explique
plusieurs fois que papa malheureusement
et qu'il est parti et qui va beaucoup
manquer
forcément il va beaucoup nous manquer
lui aussi est très vite me suis dit
papa avant de partir et m'a laissé un
message pour toi donc là tu es petit
mais je leur dirai je leur dirai je te
dirai oui voilà ce qui m'a dit papa déjà
il a dit qu'il aimait tous ses enfants
mais ils avaient quand même son chouchou
c'est toi donc tant pis pour eux tu
restes sont prêtes tu reste le préféré
j'ai donc testé le chulo de papa s'il
applique sous l'eau donc j'étais tout le
papa tu est le préféré de papa et je
suis dit tu faisais quoi avec mapa il
donc il m'explique qu'il allait au
cinéma avec lui puisque mon mari
l'emmener tous les samedis au cinéma
donc j'ai dit ben justement papa il a
dit que tout ce que tu faisais avec lui
c'est maman qui va le faire maintenant
est ce que tu sais où est ce qu'il est
le cinéma oui il est là et alors tu je
tâcherai de quoi tu aime papa m'a dit
acheter des pop corn nuit après bien sûr
je vais pour enchaîner dix et les
boissons 6 et les boissons et après j'ai
gentiment j'ai gentiment dit que son
père avait un message pour lui qu'il
aimait énormément qu'il avait beaucoup
lui manquer et qu'il fallait après j'en
ai profité
je suis dit il va pas il attend de toi
et que tu as you pour que tu sois un bon
élève que tu arrive le premier à l'école
le premier de la classe et que tu sois
gentil que tu lui fasse honneur et puis
voilà toujours courage c est ce que vous
avez à dire des roues à dire ce soir un
dernier message à faire passer
mais mon mari c'était une belle âme une
belle âme et
et j'ai envie de je suis même intimement
convaincu qu'une belle âme comme ça
quand elle pas s'exercer forcément la
cause pour une plainte très belles
choses et vous souvient je soutiens ce
que ma mère dit cesserai jamais de
l'aimer comme tout enfant qui perd ses
parents
et aujourd'hui je partage vraiment
sentiment là et et je suis prête à faire
le nécessaire dans la vie pour soutenir
tous ces gens là aussi qu'ils m'ont ses
enfants et et de réaliser les rêves que
mon père il a voulu évident a voulu
faire merci je voulais vous remercier
doria et sofia géant on a mis en place
une pétition qui est juste là un mort de
plus un mort de trop donc je demande à
ceux qui nous regardent et ceux qui ne
regardent qu'ils en parlent à leurs amis
à leurs familles et que ça prend deux
minutes et kissin ou la voie là où la
mettra à l'antenne
plusieurs fois merci merci infiniment
merci au dessous de moi que je fais
merci